how much is university going to cost me
so there are two components to expense
at university you have your tuition fees
and your living costs or maintenance
your tuition fees will be nine thousand
pounds per year if you're applying from
the UK and they can be between fifteen
and twenty one thousand pounds per year
if you're applying from overseas though
this can be higher for clinical medicine
these fees aren't all payable upfront
and you can get a loan to cover them
from the UK government if you are
applying from the first undergraduate
degree and from the UK or the EU more
information about that here and note the
Oxford also provides reduced tuition
fees for students based on household
income so if you're from a low income
family then you can save up to three
thousand pounds per year on your tuition
fees more low information about that
scheme here now when it comes to living
costs this will obviously vary a lot
from person to person based on your
spending habits but generally you can
expect to spend between one thousand and
one and a half thousand pounds per month
for everything for the six months that
you'll be at university both Oxford and
Cambridge provide estimates for living
costs at the universities which can be
found here and here and again a loan is
available from the UK governments to
cover these costs more information about
which can be found here secondly what
kind of financial assistance is
available now if you are a UK student
then in addition to applying for a
tuition fee loan from the student loans
company you are also eligible to receive
funding to your living costs and the
amount available to you will vary
depending on where you're from in the UK
regardless of household income you can
apply for a maintenance loan and if
you're from a low income background you
can also apply for a non repayable
maintenance grant information about this
can be found here in terms of financial
support both universities make it their
mission that no student should have to
decline and offer to study there because
of financial reasons Oxford has a
fantastically generous bursary scheme
offering up to four and a half thousand
pounds per year in non repayable grants
based on household income in addition to
this there are other scholarships and
grants available for more information
you can check out these two links while
cambridge offers a very generous bursary
scheme as well offering up to ten
thousand pounds over three years again
assessed based on household income more
information about that check out this
link lastly it's worth noting that
neither Oxford or Cambridge allow you to
work whilst you're at university
with the exception of some bar shifts in
your college and frankly even if you
wanted to work you probably wouldn't
have time to the eight-week terms are
incredibly intense and if you were in
the position where you needed financial
support from a job to continue studying
then funds would be available to you
from the University also remember that
the short terms mean that you have a lot
of time spend at home where you can take
on part-time employment to support
yourself though again if this is
necessary of you to continue studying
then funds will be available to you
either from the University or from your
college